[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd unboxing video go ahead and watch in
hd down there uh but this is actually a
package from richard solo as you can see
by the title and is actually really
generously sent out to me and i'm saying
that because there is more than one item
in this package in fact there is a lot
of stuff in this small package here and
i'm proud to unbox these things and will
definitely review everything in the
package
before including them in a possible
giant giveaway uh so i'm definitely
gonna get to you guys with reviews of
everything in this package uh celestia
unboxing and first impressions of
everything in the package so here we go
guys
just go ahead and open this up here and
um i'll walk you through everything
that's in here step by step name by name
uh as well as i can so i'll just move
that paper out of the way
first thing you'll see here is the
richard solo 1800 backup battery which
does have you know the laser the usb
will charge your ipod touch your iphone
everything ipod um via a cable so that
is the first thing in this box
let's keep going through here
the second thing you'll see is actually
a richard solo 1200 backup battery which
actually plugs directly in
buy this out of the uh the case right
here let's just go ahead and uh cut the
plastic here we go
so here's the uh the custom case uh the
instructions on it say yeah there we go
there's two parts and uh that's that's
the way you'll be able to put it on to
your ipod or iphone or your iphone 3gs
uh this is the you know it's very
standard case very simple and you can go
ahead and visit richard solo's website
if you want to go ahead and customize
that case that little notch right there
is how it connects so that's very cool
thanks richard solo
i'm sure people will love to see the
reviews of these kinds of things
very very nice that they're able to send
this out to me
let's just go ahead and uh take a look
inside the richard solo 1200 box see if
i can give you guys my first impressions
of the richard solo battery uh the first
years of solo battery
and as you can see on the box or if you
want to go ahead and check out the
website there are a number of uh
features besides just battery charging
uh about these these backup batteries
that are that are really making them uh
very convenient
so here's what comes in the box you get
obviously your instructions here
and you'll get the battery the charger
and the usb cable very very standard
makes sense and uh that'll be nice to
review um you know give you some
information about the charging up times
how long it lasts etc and now let's just
go ahead and check out the 1800 just
open the box up right there
and
there it is
so it actually comes with two smaller
boxes and that's understandable because
in one box you'll find i'm assuming the
cables oh no in this box you'll find the
actual battery this is a smaller box
you'll find the battery and you'll find
the connection with the cable
and in the other box you will see
all the cables and stuff of course so we
have
what looks like a car charger here
and the the usb cable is here
put those on camera
you will have the the actual wall
charger
and that is almost it actually there's a
little bit more in here
the oops the the actual cable that
connects it to your ipod which makes
sense and a little instruction manual so
there's a lot of stuff in the 1800 box
including the uh surprisingly sleek
1800s very nice
uh so uh thanks to richard solo again
for sending these out to me very very
cool and you will see reviews of
everything you see here in the near
future uh everything again one to three
weeks after it comes out um
and yeah i just can't wait to get you
guys with a review video so again thanks
for watching thank you richard solo for
sending these things out very very nice
and i'll catch you guys in the next
video thanks for watching guys peace